as much as actors often love to remind
the audience that on-screen kissing
is just another part of their job we
know that some of those up-close and
personal moments have to go better than
others
fortunately some stars have kissed and
told and
the results are revealing the greatest
showman makes its audience wait
until almost the very end to see the
electric chemistry between playwright
zac efron's character philip and trapeze
artist zendaya's character anne
payoff in a poignant kiss the
star-crossed couple finally gives in to
their desire for each other
after he nearly dies trying to save her
from a fire
waking up in a hospital philip finds
anne waiting at his bedside
possibly defying medical advice they
finally smooch
ephron felt that the moment was worth
the wait too
although he's previously been nominated
for not one but two
mtv movie awards for best kiss he told
film web tv
this might be my favorite kiss i think
ever just cause
at this point for these characters the
tension between them is so strong that
literally just a glance between them is
electric
and when they finally have the courage
to finally connect
and get that kiss it's that epic
beautiful moment
zendaya happened to be sitting next to
ephron when he paid her that pretty
impressive compliment she responded very
coolly by raising her eyebrows to the
camera
and adding that kiss pays off for the
audience it's like
ah finally at least one person thinks
chris pratt comes out on top in
something
bryce dallas howard proved it when she
told people that in the moment pratt
kissed her in jurassic world
chris's breath was like starburst he's
perfect in
every way ironically the co-star's
jurassic world kiss
wasn't even supposed to happen pratt and
director colin trevorrow decided that
after following the script and shooting
a take with
no kiss pratt would surprise howard on
the next take
in front of 800 extras that look of
surprise in the final version
is real honestly eating a few starbursts
beforehand
is the least he could do fortunately
howard had only positive things to say
about working with pratt
she told out magazine he is a very
attractive human being
he's just like the best guy there's
nothing more handsome than a humble
heart
she wasn't the only one who approved of
the spontaneous kiss
howard said that after trevorrow ended
that take everyone in the background
started cheering
quote it was great if you really have to
kiss someone in front of 100 crew
members and a handful of co-stars
multiple times a week for years
it's preferable to have that person also
be your partner off screen
at least that's what penn badgley
discovered when he was working on gossip
girl
on watch what happens live badgley was
asked who his best
and worst on-screen kissing partners
have been he shared
on-screen kisses are not really that
real but i'll say it was blake
because we actually had a relationship
at the time badgley dated his co-star
blake lively from 2007 to 2010.
their respective characters dan and
serena had an on off relationship for
the show's entire six season run which
ended in 2012. the mathematicians among
you will notice that dan and serena were
together
ish for two years longer than badgley
and lively
this explains badgley's pick for worst
on-screen kissing partner
and then the worst maybe blake after we
broke up
no no no let me guess you can explain
however he added that he and lively were
professional throughout the final two
awkward seasons
which culminate spoiler alert in dan and
serena getting married badgely
summarized by saying quote
we handled it loose lips sink ships but
in the world war ii period piece
atonement
one romantic scene also got audiences
talking in addition to lip locking it
involves a green silk dress
a library and a creative use for
bookshelves the chemistry between keira
knightley's character
cecilia and her childhood friend ravi
played by james mcavoy
is palpable nightly was feeling the heat
with her co-star too by the time she
made atonement she'd already shared
on-screen kisses with such partners as
orlando bloom in pirates of the
caribbean
shall we tell a geophore and andrew
lincoln in love actually
clive owen and king arthur and matthew
mcfadyen
in pride and prejudice but while
promoting atonement at the venice film
festival
she told the chicago tribune james is
the best kisser ever
to be fair to the others mcavoy was
there with her at the time
so it would have been extremely awkward
if she'd named someone else
although the multi-talented singer
dancer and actor has had the opportunity
to kiss multiple hollywood a-listers
over the course of her illustria's
career
jennifer lopez went with a relatively
obscure pick when it was time to offer
up her choice for best on-screen kisser
in 2014 lopez told watch what happens
live that josh lucas
is her favorite on-screen kiss he played
her love interest in the 2005 drama an
unfinished life lopez told andy cohen
i felt and i hope he would say the same
that we had a very good kiss
she explained that the scene involved
some challenging maneuvers in the back
of a truck
saying i think we were both really
nervous and then he was like
that was really good i was like yeah
that was really good
lucas confirmed lopez's account when he
appeared on the show in 2015
asked about his favorite kiss he said i
gotta agree with jennifer lopez she was
phenomenal in many ways
lucas also explained that the scene was
ultimately cut so the movie could get a
pg rating
it's good to know that the chemistry was
mutual even if we never got to see it in
action
anyone who still hasn't found a love
story to match titanic will
understand leonardo dicaprio's pick for
his favorite on-screen kissing partner
of his career when dicaprio was asked
which leading lady was his favorite to
kiss
on the oprah winfrey show in 2004 he
said
i'm just gonna go with kate winslet the
show played a 1998 clip of winslet
saying very nice things about dicaprio
including how great he was to work with
and how close they grew over the shoot
dicaprio agreed
if it wasn't for her making that film we
would have been shrapnel by this point
it was just the toughest film we ever
had to make and we were partners
together
you know we held each other's hand and
supported each other
however winslet herself let out the
secret that dicaprio wasn't always so
happy about those titanic
kissing scenes after crashing a red
carpet interview with dicaprio at a 2005
sag awards
winslet revealed i can tell you right
now he hated it
dicaprio denied this at first but then
explained that the main issue was
something that had nothing to do with
their chemistry
instead it was really just that the
pair's different colored foundations
would rub off on each other's faces
winslet and dicaprio are famously still
good friends even reuniting in 2008
for a much less romantic movie
revolutionary road
even though dicaprio has kissed many
more leading ladies
since that 2004 declaration we all know
he's never let go of his titanic
teammate
some people get nervous just talking to
someone they admire
not sharon stone she was actually
excited to shoot a kissing scene with
her favorite actor
on a 2020 episode of watch what happens
live stone was asked which of the men
she's acted opposite was the best kisser
stone named robert de niro quote far and
away
she and deniro played husband and wife
in the 1995 gangster movie casino
stone explained that she'd always wanted
to work with de niro and that admiration
made her even more excited to shoot
romantic scenes with him
maybe because i just held him in such
extraordinary high regard
and there was so much attached to it but
kissing him was pretty fabulous
so i don't know that i could compare
anything else to that anything else
is just kind of like meh surprisingly
stone almost didn't take the role in
casino
she was told that the character a mother
who neglects her child to do drugs
was too unsympathetic but once she'd
auditioned and
landed the part stone felt that de niro
and director martin scorsese were the
first people to truly understand her
potential as an actor
she told the guardian to get the pat on
your back from your peers
is always pretty great heath ledger
earned a posthumous oscar for his
sinister portrayal of the joker in the
dark knight but many fans will always
remember him best
as the lead in many of their favorite
romantic movies they'll be pleased to
know that his leading ladies in those
terrier pictures very much enjoyed
working with him on watch what happens
live
in 2014 kate hudson was asked which of
her on-screen love interests
other than wish i was here co-star zac
braff
who was sitting right next to her was
the best kisser hudson replied that it
was ledger
whom she starred opposite in the 2002
war drama
the four feathers she recalled that was
pretty excellent
he was just so beautiful and sweet and
gentle he was lovely
if you were expecting hudson to choose
frequent rom-com collaborator matthew
mcconaughey it might
ease your disappointment to know that
she had good reasons not to pick that
particular leading man for this honor
she told entertainment tonight that she
and mcconaughey always find themselves
in weird situations while shooting
kissing scenes that made things a bit
awkward she explained we're kissing
after a plane crash
and like in the water i have yet to have
the kiss with matthew that's just like
kind of simple despite playing a series
of charmingly self-deprecating
heartthrobs
hugh grant has freely admitted that he's
not exactly popular with many of his
former leading ladies
it's no wonder though when oprah asked
him about kissing julia roberts his
response was less than gentlemanly
she has a very big mouth when i was
kissing her i was aware of a faint echo
he also admitted to making drew
barrymore cry on the set of their
rom-com
music and lyrics but the two reunited
virtually for an interview
in 2020. however grant did have fun with
one co-star
and they're still friends he told
british talk show host
ellen carr that renee zellweger is quote
a top snogger
grant played bad boy daniel cleaver
opposite zellweger's bridget jones in
the first two movies of the iconic
trilogy
furthermore he's pretty sure that even
though bridgette ultimately ends up with
cleaver's rival mark darcy
played by cullen firth zellweger still
had more fun kissing grant
he shared you'd have to ask zellweger
who she preferred but i think
colin tried too hard i think that was
the problem fighting words indeed
especially considering that grant didn't
return for the third installment in the
series
leaving zellweger kissing not only first
but also her character's new love
interest
jack quant played by patrick dempsey
meryl streep is famous for getting
completely absorbed in a role and she
brings that energetic enthusiasm to her
kissing scenes
as emma thompson found out as to had
been her best on-screen kiss
thompson first named robbie coltrane she
kissed him in the
bbc series tutti frutti in which they
played rock stars in the fictional
scottish band the majestics
that's right kids hagrid and professor
trelawny were once each other's love
interests
and made out on stage for a tv show
although thompson admitted
it turned into a bit of a tooth kiss
thompson also once played the love
interest of her close friend alan
rickman
also known as professor snape so the
harry potter universe was already pretty
awkward
thompson went on to add meryl streeps a
very good snogger
the two actresses kissed in a 2003 hbo
adaptation of the celebrated play angels
in america
thompson recalled she was method about
it there was no stone unturned in my gob
that's for sure
i thought blimey what's she doing here
mining for jewels
in case you were wondering thompson's
advice on preparing for a kissing scene
is to avoid
tuna sandwiches beforehand and go easy
on the teeth
shooting romantic scenes is famously
uncomfortable but ethan hawk found the
bright side when he was matched with
angelina jolie
in the 2004 serial killer thriller
taking lives
nearly a decade later hawk was still
telling multiple interviewers that jolie
was his favorite person to kiss
on screen on radio shows way in the
morning in 2012
hawk said that he was nervous about
filming his love scene with jolie
because of the crowded set
and because well she's angelina jolie
hawke stated she cuts an intimidating
figure but it turned out to be one of
the finest days of my life
according to hawke jolie suggested that
she get naked while hawk stayed fully
clothed he recalls that all of a sudden
he wasn't nervous at all
hawk opened up a little more the
following year in an appearance on watch
what happens live
possibly with a respectable amount of
assistance from the show's famous bar
hawk tried to explain why jolie was his
favorite performed kiss
saying why is wolfgang amadeus mozart a
genius
angelina jolie was born to whittlemen to
make them weak
when she kisses you you don't know your
name will ferrell
isn't much known for being a romantic
lead but maybe he should be given that
two actresses who've been lucky enough
to lock lips with
him have attested to his kissing
abilities in 2007
amy adams who kissed feral and talladega
knights
the ballad of ricky bobby managed to
compliment and
mildly insult farrell in one breath
adams said
he's a fantastic kisser i was not
expecting that
adams also complimented enchanted
co-star patrick dempsey whom she
described as lovely
but it's clear farrell impressed her the
most a couple of years later
ferrell also got a vote of kissing
confidence from land of the lost co-star
anna freel
like adams friel delivered a backhanded
compliment when she declared
will ferrell is a really fantastic
kisser you wouldn't expect it from him
he's got twinkly blue eyes and he was
gentler than i thought that he perhaps
might be
despite farrell's reputation for comedy
over romance he has had quite a few
kisses on film
farrell himself noted in 2017 that
someone had kindly counted 15
up to that point but he humbly added i
don't know what that says
it says people listened to adam's and
friel
sure kissing other actors is all part of
the job but that doesn't mean that work
can't sometimes be fun the 1988 movie
big had tom hanks playing a 12 year old
named josh who is suddenly transformed
into an adult and
lands his dream job testing toys
elizabeth perkins who played josh's love
interest
susan had a good day at work when they
shot their kissing scenes
in 2021 when asked which kiss on screen
she still
fondly remembers years later on watch
what happens live
perkins named her scenes with hanks in
big the kisses themselves were
relatively innocent
since his character was technically 12
but perkins was still impressed
by her scene partner she admitted i had
such a crush on hanks at the time
at the time perkins was single but hanks
was dating his current wife
rita wilson noting this perkins added
that while he was quote completely off
limits he was adorable
ironically she almost had a different
partner to pucker up with
in the same interview perkins said that
robert de niro originally signed up to
play josh
but was replaced by hanks due to
scheduling conflicts
that's a big difference jennifer
lawrence is famously direct
and that extends to discussing her
on-screen kissing partners
but her top choice isn't necessarily who
you'd expect
based on her off-screen love life in
2015 on watch what happens live
lawrence confirmed that she and hunger
games love interest
liam hemsworth took their kissing
chemistry off screen at some point
as she explained liam and i grew up
together liam's real hot
what would you have done lawrence also
doesn't shy away from offering
constructive feedback to her film love
interests in 2013
her frequent collaborator bradley cooper
told the graham norton show that
while shooting silver linings playbook
lawrence told him he was quote a wet
kisser
and it was not a compliment however the
pair still picked up an
mtv movie award for best kiss they also
went on to kiss in 2014's
serena cooper must have taken lawrence's
advice to heart
because in 2018 when ellen degeneres
asked lawrence whether hemsworth or
cooper was the better kisser
she said cooper to be fair hemsworth
didn't necessarily relish those kissing
scenes either
at least that's what he told jimmy
fallon in 2014.
if we had a kissing scene she would make
a point of eating
garlic or tuna fish amanda seifried has
been refreshingly open about the highs
and lows of shooting love scenes one
kiss in particular stands out to her
because she
and her partner clicked so well in 2014
w magazine reported that saifriend said
that she
and co-star megan fox quote kissed
really well together
she added we have similar kissing styles
if i watch the scene
it's actually really sexy sci-fred also
had great chemistry with co-star dominic
cooper who played her groom in mamma mia
the pair even started dating after the
movie wrapped
however they split after four years
which made reuniting to play the now
married couple in mamma mia 2
a little awkward working with an ex is
hard enough
but having to kiss them as part of your
job is a whole other dynamic
especially since syfred's husband was on
set for some of their kissing scenes
as seyfried explained to elle it's very
strange having to not
be intimate with someone you've had an
intimate relationship with
but dominic and i have such a good
relationship that it was easy
cooper backed up her account telling
attitude that the atmosphere on set was
pleasant
and that he enjoyed catching up with
seifred seeing how different their lives
were
after 10 years if you feel that the most
believable element of the transformers
franchise is the chemistry between megan
fox
and shia labeouf fox partially agrees in
2014
she told e news that la buff was her
favorite kiss on screen
that may be because the actors were
diligently rehearsing their kissing
scenes in real life
in 2011 la buff admitted to details that
he
and fox had a romantic relationship on
the set of transformers
although it's not clear if he meant the
first or second movie in the franchise
which came out in 2007
and 2009 respectively la buff put it
down to a long shoot
saying in the film someone is rooting to
be attracted to you and you're rooting
to be attracted to them
awkwardly fox was thought to have been
in a relationship with actor brian
austin green
from 2004 until february 2009
they reconciled marrying in june 2010
but officially split
in may 2020 asked about their status at
the time of his relationship with fox
labeouf said quote i don't know man also
awkwardly he didn't return
fox's compliment he said dakota johnson
was his favorite kissing partner
even still in 2018 fox confirmed la
buff's claims
telling watch what happens live that she
would confirm that their on-set
relationship was romantic
when andy cohen suggested it had been an
on-set romance that didn't go anywhere
afterwards fox said
yeah they'll always have transformers
there is in fact a way to publicly
applaud a co-star's kissing skills while
also keeping the conversation
classy exhibit a oprah winfrey and
forest whitaker have both spoken highly
of their experience playing a romantic
couple
in the butler speaking to her close
friend gail king on cbs news to promote
the movie
winfrey said of her co-star quote i
adore him when king
asked whether kissing whitaker made her
quote feel all tingly
winfrey said i felt pretty good about it
let me just say
forrest is a good kisser she then
jokingly and honestly thanked kesha
whitaker
whitaker's wife the couple has been
married since 1996.
the feeling is mutual talking to the
source whitaker described their
character's relationship as the closest
he's ever portrayed on screen
he said of his co-star she's amazing i
loved working with her
i haven't had a lot of love
relationships on screen none
is as intimate as this one even better
than hearing that you're someone's
favorite on-screen kisser has to be
hearing that multiple former co-stars
were impressed with your smooching
skills
you'd have to ask tom cruise for insight
into this experience
as his kissing has been publicly
acclaimed by at least three of his
former leading ladies
in 1996 shelley long of cheers fame told
rosie o'donnell that she
and cruz had kissed in a movie called
losing it which came out
right before risky business made him a
star asked if cruz was a good kisser
long said i would rate him very highly
long added that she doesn't typically
rank her leading men's kissing abilities
but if she did
cruz was quote off the scale fast
forward to 2013
leah thompson also known as marty
mcfly's mom
in back to the future recalled starring
opposite cruz in all the right moves
which hit theaters just after risky
business and before top gun
she seemed to rank cruz's kissing
abilities highly too
saying there's something about the way
he pays attention the way he
cruz looks at you like he's really
looking at you although thompson pointed
out that he might have gone downhill
since 1983
evidence suggests otherwise in 2011
gwyneth paltrow reminisced on the rachel
ray show about kissing crews in their
2002's austin powers and gold member
cameo
paltrow recalled he was an amazing
kisser
one undeniable truth of buffy the
vampire slayer is that the show's fans
are fiercely divided over which of the
heroine's vampire love interests
is superior if they're hoping that
finding out sarah michelle gellar's
favorite on-screen kissing partner might
solve that fight
they're in for a disappointment when
asked who her favorite performed kiss
came from in 2014
geller said selma blair that's easy she
is of course referring to her famous
makeout with blair
and cruel intentions the kiss not only
won them the 2000
mtv movie award for best kiss it also
nabbed the legendary lip lock award
at the mtv greatest of all time awards
in 2021
geller expanded on what made the kiss so
memorable for her
she told us weekly selma's a great
kisser it's just
soft lips she smells great and then we
had ice cream
sorry team spikes and angel drew
barrymore and adam sandler have played a
couple multiple times and it may be true
that he won her over
on their very first movie together in
2009
barrymore told people magazine that
hercus with sandler in the wedding
singer was her favorite kissing scene
she shared it was really innocent and
unsalacious
really romantic and fun i think adam is
the greatest guy
so it's easy to be in love with him
however barrymore isn't the only woman
sandler has had to impress with his
romantic performances
in 2014 on a joint appearance on ellen
sandler said that his wife jackie whom
he married in 2003
is a big fan of barrymore's and will
give him feedback if she feels that he's
not being romantic enough towards her in
a scene
recalling shooting a particular scene
for their 2014 comedy blended
sandler said that he initially felt that
he'd done a good job
until he walked offset to a frustrated
jackie who told him
for the sake of women get in there and
just look a little more alive
it is after all your real-life partner
whose approval you should be most
interested in
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite celebrities
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you